can i ask you in a small tangent
uh to talk about your um
favorite
set of ideas and and people which is
post-modernism
what
what is what is post-modernism how would
you define it and
why
to you is it not a useful framework of
thought
post-modernism is something that i'm
really not an expert on
and post-modernism is a
set of philosophical ideas that is
difficult to lamp together
that
is characterized by some useful thinkers
some of them post structuralist and so
on and i'm mostly not interested in it
because i i think that it's not leading
me anywhere that i find particularly
useful
it's mostly i think born out of the
inside that the ontologies that we
impose on the world are not literally
true and that we can often get to a
different interpretation by the world by
using a different anthology that is
different separation of the world into
interacting objects
but the idea that this makes the world a
set of stories
that are arbitrary i think is wrong
and the people that are engaging in this
type of philosophy
are working in in an area that i largely
don't find productive there's nothing
useful coming out of this so this idea
that truth is relative is not something
that has in some sense informed physics
or theory of relativity and there is no
feedback between those there is no
meaningful influence of this type of
philosophy on the sciences or in
engineering or in politics but there is
a very strong information on
of this on
ideology
because it basically has become an
ideology that is justifying itself by
the notion that truth is a relative
concept
and it's not being used in such a way
that the the philosophers that or
sociologists that take up these ideas
say oh uh i should doubt my own ideas
because maybe my separation of the world
into objects is not completely valid and
they should maybe use the different one
and be open to a pluralism of ideas
but it mostly exists to dismiss the
ideas of other people
it becomes yeah it becomes a political
weapon of sorts
to achieve power basically this
there's nothing wrong i think with
developing a philosophy around this but
to develop norms around the idea that
truth is something that is completely
negotiable is incompatible with the
scientific project
and i think if uh the uh if the academia
has no defense against the ideological
parts of
the postmodernist movement it's doomed
right you have to acknowledge the
ideological part of any movement
actually
including postmodernism well the
question is what an ideology is and to
me an ideology is basically a viral
memplex
that is changing your mind in such a way
that reality gets warped
it gets warped in such a way that you're
being cut off from the rest of human
thought space and you cannot consider
things outside of the range of ideas of
your own ideology and pos as possibly
true right so i mean there's certain
properties to an ideology that make it
harmful one of them is that like
dogmatism
of just certainty
dogged certainty in in that you're right
you have the truth and nobody else but
what is creating the certainty it's very
interesting to look at the type of model
that is being produced is it basically
just a strong prior and you tell people
oh this idea that you consider to be
very true the evidence for this is
actually just much weaker than you
thought and look here at some studies no
this is not how it works it's usually
normative which means
some thoughts are unthinkable
because they would change your identity
into something that is no longer
acceptable
and this cuts you off from considering
an alternative and many uh de facto
religions use this trick to lock people
into a certain mode of thought and this
removes agency over your own thoughts
it's very ugly to me it's basically not
just a process of domestication but it's
actually an intellectual castration that
happens it's an inability to think
creatively and to bring forth new
thoughts
you